welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
so could one of the most underrated
sci-fi shows of the 90s be getting a
reboot
babylon 5 has been on hbo max over the
last few months and its show creator
michael j strzinski has gone on to
twitter to tell everyone about it but
also to tell everyone that you can
actually go on amazon and see the full
scripts so you can actually read the
full series and all those little bits
that never quite made the screen
during that conversation adjust crozier
made
a flippant comment
wish we could get some new b5 yeah i
know i can dream car i the show created
though j michaelskinski answered and he
said
who knows this might not be so well the
dreams it appears so what's that is he
just teasing us or is there some
preliminary conversations going on
part of the why hbo has put babylon 5
onto their streaming service in the
first place is as a precursor to maybe
us getting a reboot
the babylon project was our last best
hope for peace
[Music]
it failed
[Music]
but in the year of the shadow war it
became something greater
our last best hope
for victory
the year is 2260.
the place babylon 5.
now back in 2018
j markinski talked about how there was
absolutely no chance pablo 5 was going
to be getting a remake it's owned by
warner brothers and they're not
interested
but
we know that all of the streaming
services at the moment are screaming out
for new content
they
it's one of the reasons why netflix is
so massively in debt because they
plow so much money into content content
content the disney plus threat to that
the the juggernaut that is disney is
swallowing up content every chance it
gets and it's one of the reasons why i
firmly believe we're going to see new
series of stargate and probably even
firefly but would i want to see battle 5
come back
like i said i genuinely believe it was
one of the most underrated sci-fi shows
of the 90s it did have an incredibly low
budget don't get me wrong and there was
lots of things wrong with the series
the first season in particular was
actually quite dull i didn't like
captain sinclair but that's why we got
sheridan in the second series
there are elements to the story that i
absolutely adored them i love that we
see humanity at its best
building the babylon 5 station for
example is us at us best it's just
wanted to create a place in neutral
space for diplomacy and trade
i just wanted to project peace into the
galaxy we also saw though humanity at
its worst when we were afraid
and
i do think that that is something that
reflects our current culture
we also saw a realistic
vision of the future in babylon 5 where
we had the lower decks sort of the brown
zones where people maybe didn't have
enough where the resources of the galaxy
didn't spread so that everybody was
lived in peace and had full bellies and
so on maybe not like the star trek
version of the universe of the future
that also kind of reflects our current
culture and the world today and i think
good sci-fi should do that it should
reflect the world that it we live in it
should reflect our culture there should
be a moral to the story without
necessarily ramming that moral down your
throat so i do think this is a story
that
can be told again and can be told in a
new way that again as i say reflects the
world 30 years on i think enough time
has gone by though that a reboot
can work but also
a sequel to the series can't really work
because it would smash the cannon of the
original series too badly one of the
things j mike krusinski did was created
a full arc in that series it had a
beginning and at the middle it had an
end
and i think that should be left as it
was
but there are some things i'd love to
see in far more detail the babylon 5
movie of call to arms was probably my
favorite part of the series other than
series 3 another the the finale of the
shadow war was epic don't get me wrong
but i want to see more about the mimbari
war i'd love to see maybe at the start
of babylon five the mumbari aren't
really
involved
so i think they're they're sort of on
the outskirts and perhaps we see the
beginning of the minbara conflict in the
first series i'd love to see a
reimagining of how the mumbari war
started because it was so cleverly done
in the film
basically the earth force approached the
mambari fleet they didn't know anything
about each other
earth forced closed their weapon doors
they were saying we're not a threat
we're not here to attack you the mumbai
though had a different philosophy they
opened their weapon doors their attitude
being this is what we have
you can see what we are armed with and
we are not going to attack you we are
not a threat
those different philosophies is what
triggered the war when somebody on an
earth force vessel panicked and fired
first
babylon 5 could exist in that universe
because obviously it's supposed to be
a neutral zone and we could see that
maybe being respected during the first
series where it's kind of like a hub for
what is going on
we then maybe see i would love to see
the serious finale is when the war comes
to babylon 5 and hopefully through some
brilliance of negotiation we see an end
to that conflict but all the way through
that series we should start getting
hints of the shadow threat as that is
why the conflict is forced to end
i never really liked the souls thing
you know the the the conflict came to an
end because they realized when irish
souls were being reincarnated into
humans and i actually quite liked why
humans never really understood why the
minbari surrendered why they ended the
conflict
um so that was really clever
but two of the most important things
they have to get right with this series
if it does make a reboot they have to
get some of the characters right
so
replacing sheridan is vital like i said
the first series of bubble on five
wasn't particularly good and sadly one
of those reasons was captain sinclair
wasn't a particularly charismatic
character
when bruce latina came in he brought
that charisma he brought a captain we
liked
and just you know brought a whole new
energy to the series i have to get a
vaniva right
the captain's number two
the conflict between them so often at
heads with each other but together at
the same time brought a really
interesting dynamic to the command
structure of babylon 5.
as did garibaldi and his character the
flawed human being that always kind of
reminded me of bruce willis character
from die hard i don't know why
um
getting him right again is so important
because his character
was so important into the unraveling of
the shadow threat and all the sort of
background things that were going on
particularly with the centauri
actually getting the centauri right is
really important because they were a big
part of the show they brought a lot
obviously the the corruption and the
and the sort of the twists in the
background that was going on but also
they brought a sort of a comic element
to the series and getting the volume
right is important because obviously
towards the end of the shadow war
their character completely turned and
they went from being the hope of the
galaxy really the most powerful sort of
species in the galaxy to their biggest
threat
they're
logical in the way they think i don't
want to see them appear as an angel
again but other than that the volons
were such an important character and
getting them right in some sort of
reboot is going to be vital and i don't
mind if this show changes a little bit
if it comes back with some different
twists modernize it but a couple of
things i'd like to see not change too
much the babolus 5 station design was
brilliantly thought through it was
clever
and it looked great
don't change it too much
the star furies is still one of my
favorite fighter designs in all of
sci-fi
your escort's in place
thank you commander finishing systems
check
ready for launch you're clear for drop
happy hunting
it's one of those designs you actually
think that could work in real life and
it just looked amazing
the mambari ships looked great the earth
falls ships even i like how they were
sort of lower tech we didn't have
artificial gravity so they've got that
big section that rotates to create it so
if they keep those elements
modernize them a little bit but not too
much
bring in some really good characters
there is a core plot to this series that
could be rebooted and remade that would
make a really great modern tv show for
some streaming service probably hbo
and out of all of the series at the
moment that we're looking at perhaps
getting a reboot stargate firefly
babylon 5 is the one that may not be the
most successful
but it is the one that might be the most
interesting so thanks
if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit that bell
notification it really helps us out for
all of these little videos i do and i'll
see you next time
[Music]